Being the fastest is, in my opinion, not the right expression.
Moving boundaries might be the right expression.
And right now, heading for the 300 mile barrier for a series hyper sports car,...
...this is the boundary we were heading for.
And this is what we'd like to achieve.
The biggest challenge is to get the overall package right.
So, that means not only design not only aerodynamics, not only engine, not only tires,...
...is to get everything together and working in one car.
At that kind of speed, normally airplanes are flying in the air.
And you have to make sure that the car will stay on the ground, stable...
...and not that nervous.
That the driver feels comfortable in the car...
...and that you can drive that kind of speed without any risk.
What a fantastic car!
I can't thank you enough.
To get everything works, together in one moment.
And to head for the 300 mile boundary,...
...it was like heading for the pinnacle of automobile competition.